today we're going to be choosing
piercings for each other I don't know
why but we are because we're best
friends I haven't gotten my ears pierced
since I was 17 I feel like they kind of
make you a little bit more badass and I
want to be edgier so I've had this guy
on my face since I was 21 so definitely
looking forward to getting other person
this is what I grew up with this kind of
style I don't know if I trust is about
to pick for me cuz she seems really
sweet but I feel like we've been best
friends for 12 years I trust you with my
life you trust me with yours I think I
do yeah you know you pretty much I am
very nervous he's in control I can't
choose where my face is gonna go so we
have each other's picture and we're
supposed to draw the piercing that we
want for the other person but what I
want to get ferati isn't on this photo
it's on this guy
[Music]
we did agree yesterday that we're not
getting any type of genital-piercing
putting that out there this will make
her look like a badass and I think like
bees will be nice for her boyfriend
welcome do that it would be professional
when you need to be professional and you
could have fun when you want to I was I
was thinking about getting like how
eyebrow done so I've decided to go with
writing it yeah I think I might actually
just go with the lower lip ones I wanted
to happen that you're either give me a
lip piercing I am and he had this photo
on Instagram she clearly wants that
because that's face because I am a good
friend
we're piercing her vagina today we're
piercing her nose just like she won I
was thinking about getting at the septum
I know your mom is gonna like kick my
ass because she's gonna be like what did
you do to my son because now be getting
a nipple piercing I had roof on tech
Oddie has like the tiniest movies ever
my name is Bryan Keith Thompson I am the
owner of body electric tattoo and I'm
excited about today all right what we're
gonna do first we're gonna clean and
then we're gonna mark your support
I don't want your supports ready buddy
please it's like it's like the size of
mine for my new a little nervous I don't
think it's like that in completely
though because I'm I don't feel like I'm
nervous enough I can make you more
nervous yeah now this is probably the
easiest piercing he'll ever get really
just like oh my god wait wait this is
gonna hurt of course is this one of the
wait there's literally hardly any pain
the only thing that's gonna happen
they're both eyes with water I'm here
for support
I'm gonna miss my nipple for a little
bit so gonna be there it's just gonna be
just gonna be decorated don't rip it
oh my god 12 years of friendship and
this is the longest I've held his hand
tonight just happened I'm not crying
because I'm sad I think you felt it more
than I did
that's what happened he did really good
never in my life you gotta admit out of
all the adventures we've been on it
looks so cute I feel like this adds to
the syllabus of this guy I'm okay with
it
you're welcome I feel good please we
both got piercings ya know if it was
just me I would have been a bit more
scared but then I got one of them you
did say ah well like closer now we're
gonna be like 50 and you know we're
gonna talk about it it's gonna be like
remember that one time you came down to
our way for a random trip and then I
asked if you wanted to get piercings
here you are with a nipple piercing now
oh we're just planning or just planning
[Music]